welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
good afternoon it's my pleasure to
welcome you to the first of the journeys
lectures the semester we had four of
them last semester starting with Randy
pouches and this semester we have four
and this is the first of the four and as
it happens the second one is again this
week on Thursday dr. Sophy Freud we'll
talk on her journey the first journeys
lecture from a person outside the campus
although you will find that she's not
totally disconnected from our campus but
today it's my honor to welcome for the
first journeys lecture of the spring
2008 semester president Jared Cohen whom
we all know have come to know and love
these years I won't give a long long
lecture about him because I should let
you hear from him about his life his
qualifications his degrees are he has an
undergraduate degree from the University
of Pennsylvania in environmental
engineering a PhD from MIT and then went
on to become faculty at Johns Hopkins
where he was vice provost for vice
president for research when he moved to
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies to be the Dean and
from bear we were fortunate enough to
attract him here in 1998 and so I give
you the eighth president of Carnegie
Mellon
Jared Cohen
Thank You Indira thank you also for your
leadership in creating this series of
lectures in for including me in it and
giving me the honor of being the first
Jerry's lecturer of the semester I've
only heard one other tourneys lecture
and that was Randy's that andheri
referred to this ain't gonna equal
Randy's lecturer I can guarantee you
that that was a remarkable event for
everybody was there and now millions of
people around the world with see it
since and I have to tell you I was just
in Europe and India and in both places
many people come in to me about Randy's
lecture having seen it on on the
Internet well this is quite a
opportunity and a task and a challenge
for me those who know me well I think
know that I don't particularly like
talking about myself I make it a
practice to be out of the country on my
birthday and which drives my wife crazy
I just don't go in for that so this sort
of celebration of Jerry is new to me but
I admire what the attorneys lectures are
all about and I'm happy to sort of play
along here and if you read my little
abstract for the lecture first of all
the title is the accidental president
and that is my theme basically the
incredible events that have occurred to
me incredible the sense of I never
expected them and I probably didn't
deserve them and the special people who
have meant so much to me and have gotten
here and it certainly was not the result
that is that I'm staying before you was
president Carnegie Mellon so it was not
a result of any life plan that I had and
in my abstract I talk
my skepticism about life plans great if
you have one but I just don't think they
amount to much because you can't really
plot out what your life is going to be
like as I say also in that I'm not a
fatalist though I do believe that
choosing goals and being ambitious are
important things to do and I recommend
that for everybody but the key thing and
I guess my major philosophical statement
here is enjoy the journey and don't
worry about too much don't worry too
much our it's going to take you this is
a very personal lecture you're about to
hear personal talk and we call it a
lecture and I'm going to focus
particularly on the people who have
influenced me so I'll fill in the
details that Indira missed i was born in
1947 in cleveland ohio so you can do the
math I'm 60 it's true I'm 60 and it
meant that I grew up in the 50s and I'm
a kid of the 60s in the sense of being
in college in the 60s I won't try to
describe you and it's like growing up in
the 50s I recommend to you instead of
wonderful book I've almost finished
Michael Murphy and his wife Nancy gave
it to me as a Christmas present but it's
bill bryson's latest book called the
life and times of the Thunderbolt kid
anybody else read this yeah you like it
it's phenomenal so one of our favorite
things to do or rate and I used to go to
our country retreat on the weekend and
sit quietly in the living room and read
the problem is every five minutes I'm
bursting wahoo laughter reading Bryson's
book it's a wonderful what he writes
wonderfully any other it's a wonderful
capturing of what it was like her up in
the 50s I grew up starting on the east
side of cleveland and the first very
important event in my life occurred in
second grade what I met my future would
that's your moment to go ah second grade
he met his wife in second grade it's
true she remembers that I was an
exceedingly polite second grader or at
least for a boy in second grade when our
class was going on a field trip the year
the Cleveland Orchestra and she was
struggling to get her coat on was
februari and I showed her the trick of
holding your she was wearing a suit
holding your seat jacket sleeve when you
stick in your come to this station
remembers that I moved away in fourth
grade leaving her behind abandoning her
for the first time to a suburb of
Cleveland called Beachwood and middle
the upper middle class incredibly
underverse suburb the school was I'd say
about 90% Jewish which I am bunny joined
me in junior year I say that she found
me it took her from fourth grade to 11th
grade to figure out where are you gone
she tracked me down and moved to be true
and we renewed our acquaintance and
started dating in senior year but i'll
come back to that almost everybody in
our class went to college and about half
of those went to Ohio State one didn't
have I don't know it's a different time
different place the kind of pressure and
stress that those along with college
applications these days and how your
life is ruined if you don't go to an Ivy
or a new IV like Carnegie Mellon just
didn't exist at that time college oh
yeah okay where should I go well why
don't you try ohio state which i did i
was interested in engineering so I
applied to Purdue also these are the
days of what they call rolling
admissions that is enlarged state
universities when they got your
application they immediately process and
if you're above a certain level in
grades I guess s80 scores are
a CT scores you got in so my grades were
high enough and issue i'll come back to
also mis 80 scores were high enough that
i got admitted right away to Ohio State
and Purdue early enough that I could
still apply elsewhere now the one thing
I can't remember and I can't figure out
is how the heck my parents got me to
fill out those applications early enough
to have been accepted before the
deadlines I it's so unlike me I must
have been having a bad day or something
but so there was and so my parents said
why don't you apply somewhere else I
said where they said how about a school
in the east meaning prestigious I said
all right where and they said how about
the Ivy League hmm ok I said I know the
rate of them which one they said go find
out which is the easiest one to get into
so I asked around we had great College
counseling in those days you ask your
friends so we all greeted was probably
pin so i applied to penn knowing nothing
about gun and even less about whether
they even had civil engineering which is
my interest and how good it was clearly
it was far inferior to purdue for sugar
and probably ohio state also and the
first time I ever saw him was when my
parents slow down long enough for me to
jump out of the car to move in her
freshman year so I chose some
engineering because at one time in my
father is somewhat checkered career he
was in the real estate and I actually
built some apartment buildings and I
watched the construction process and
I've got kind of interest in that I
thought it'd be cool to build this to
learn how to build this and civil
engineers build things so that was the
depth and extent of my career
exploration and how I chose to be a
sewage in you
so I found myself in Philadelphia in
1965 leaving Maureen at home in
Cleveland by the way her whole life
she's been known to me everybody else
that's close to her as bunny it's vito
mind dear you're going to be bunting for
the rest of them today leaving bunny
behind in Cleveland and there I was in
on the pen campus in 1965 now for those
who are not of a certain age and from
America like me you can't imagine or no
while going to college was like in the
mid to late 60s I in some respects that
was phenomenal in that this is a very
exciting time it was the 60s and pen
though not sort of the heart of the
student protest me would do I say
Columbia or Berkeley were nevertheless
had its share of unrest we were
particularly well set up for this our
president was like from central casting
he was chosen they should have he should
have worn a t-shirt that said generation
gap that his name was Gaylord hardwell
the third which I mean I could stop
right there but he was the image of the
patrician academic who had no idea what
the kids of the 60s were like and indeed
he did our orientation consisted of one
hour session in the biggest auditorium
on campus with him and the student body
president during which our class on
instruction Janet and obscene cheer in
front of this poor president and i have
to tell you more than once in my
presidency I've thought about him and
I've thought about especially when
students have come to see me say like to
protest something I'm thinking my god
I'm gaylord hard wellness
and I I there's part of me that wants to
say I'm a kid in the 60s go that's great
I don't do I got to play the part so I
sit back and look mildly disinterested
in offended that I be it's wonderful so
to add to this though I was an
incredibly immature seventeen-year-old
frankly I no business in college at that
moment in time and certainly not far
away from home for the first time so the
combination of a kid who really didn't
know what college is about any know how
to be a good student indeed I got
through high school and by virtue of
smarts and not much work added to the
60s which was sort of licensed to do any
of them try anything experiment with
anything just don't respect authority
you can do anything that was a pretty
potent combination to say that I was a
crummy student is putting it mildly that
I got married so bunny and I got married
after my sophomore year when we were 19
it was the smartest move of my life and
to show you how smart awaz this being
Carnegie Mellon you can do the math I
graduated pen with a 30 my last two
years after I got married I had a forum
Merrilee might have been a 299 I
actually didn't quite make it to 20 and
one of my first four semesters so at
least buddy saved my academic life
nothing else the Silla generic
curriculum at Penn and everywhere at
that time was extremely structured
students I want you to listen up here in
eight semesters I had exactly eight
electives so one a semester on average
and two of those are specified you can't
elect to take that English course in you
better and you can't like to take that
micro economics course and you better so
I had six electives in four years and I
did okay but as I said the latter half
much better than the former half I can't
say anything really got me excited until
I took a special course taught by a
really special guy his name is iraj
sondy it was the professor of
environmental engineering and management
the only one this was the late 60s mid
to late 60s and I took the required
course in environment and he was
terrific and I got turned on to
something that I really found
interesting and to boot I got to do
research with him I have no idea how
that came about I think I needed the
money probably but doing research with
dr. zangi meant taking this mountain of
papers he had assembled on the transport
of solid waste that's what enviro
engineers called garbage solid waste
through pipelines was the thing he was
working on and categorized in all these
papers which sounds like drudgery but I
actually really enjoyed give me a chance
to like read the literature is a work
and I really appreciated that and it was
on d and he is exposing me to this area
they got me interested
going on to graduate work and having
extremely supportive life who got me
through an array jus at school so that I
could go to graduate work I went to MIT
but let me tell you a little bit about
how I got them ID because this is very
much now getting into my characterizing
myself as the forest gump of university
presidents so I applied to Purdue again
MIT and berkeley and i was accepted in
all three I don't know admissions
departments in those days where the
sharp is there no but this was nineteen
sixty-nine it was the first year of the
draft lottery now some of you are too
young to know about this the vietnam war
was still going on and in a remarkable
moment of social fairness by the US
government there was decision to have a
lottery based on your birthday instead
of what was happening which was a bunch
of poor kids going to fight our wars and
college kids getting deference which I
was not begrudging don't get me wrong so
the deal with the lottery was they would
based on your birthday you got a lottery
number 12 365 and they predicted they
would get up to 250 to fill the
allotment that you or in the next year
and the deal with the lottery was when
you're never got called you went unless
you had some like you were physically
not able to go to the to the army but
college deferment know kind of
professional deferment you went wide
number was 234 so I figured how many a
draft and the one thing budding I didn't
want is to be in boston or berkeley
california or God figured west lafayette
indiana sorry for any Indians I just
offended
and for me to go off to war and her left
alone so I remember the weekend in April
we went home to Cleveland and I
interviewed with some engineering firms
in Cleveland a guy offered a job on the
spot and I accepted more or less on the
spot we were turn home to Philadelphia
on a sunday and there's this big package
in our mailbox from MIT and in classic
MIT fashion they didn't say because I
couldn't come out and say if you come to
MIT you will not get drafted instead
they said here's a list of every person
ever called by the Cambridge draft board
who was a student MIT and if you look at
it not a single one was ever drafted the
cambridge massachusetts in cambridge
massachusetts draft board was not like
any other draft work they were basically
saying you won't get drafted out of MIT
call the consulting company on monday
said she got sucked into MIT I
understand they said sure absolutely
that was that I went to MIT it was an
extraordinary four years nineteen sixty
nine to nineteen seventy three I was so
fortunate through in terms of timing I
happen to arrive the same day my advisor
arrived thought I know he's going to be
my advisor be turned out to be his name
is David marks still professor at MIT
MIT had decided the year before that
they were going to create a new group
within the civil engineering department
in water and environmental systems
analysis this is a new thing Harvard it
did something a few years before and
something called the Harvard water
program which was quite extraordinary
they had gotten together engineers
mathematicians economists and political
scientists with the idea of analyzing
and looking at water issues from this
new multidisciplinary and
interdisciplinary approach which may
sound not so exciting I mean to me it's
exciting
when we would look at it but it may not
sound so novel today then it was
completely new mi T's idea was we're
actually going to implement this Harvard
can dream about at MIT is going to do it
and they did well we we put together the
faculty group of Engineers operations
researchers and economist within the
cylinder in department so I found myself
part of this brand new group with these
brand new faculty and being part of a
department or program within an
apartment which is just figuring out
what it is is the most exciting time to
be affiliated with any program you talk
to our former PhD or even MBA student
super GSI a during its first few years
or first couple of decades and they'll
tell you about the intellectual
excitement of just being there just the
the interplay among faculty because they
didn't know what they were they saw you
know herb Simon and Jim marching dick
siren and Bill Cooper having these big
battles and fights about what management
science should be what business
education should be for a student it is
electrifying that's what I found myself
moving into however and I has to be said
that the MIT so engineering department
was stodgy to say the least they had
these new Young Turks but they had a
bunch of other factors there was basic
attitude was indifference and their
attitude towards the few graduate
students who opted to be in this was
sure you want to do that that's fine
that doesn't mean you're going to get
out of four semesters of hydraulics and
three semesters of hydrology and eight
semesters of water quality engineering
so I did take all of that and I'm glad I
did and there was superb stuff and
everything else on top of it but I'll
tell you it was phenomena and I mighty
was absolutely place to do it I took all
the operations research
I could fit in now operations research
was still relevant then but there are
exact roop of people at MIT who are
really pushing the boundaries of it and
there was there are two faculty members
in particular kind of wild guys who had
the bright idea that they're going to
try to unify the theory of optimal
control and mathematical program now
that's meaningless the most people in
this audience but I can't think of a the
parallel in any other field the two and
clear similarities they seek optimal
solutions to certain systems but the
systems are so different that the
mathematics are totally not totally our
almost completely separate icon to
hundreds of genera graduate students to
take this course with me which was
populated completely by double e's in
our majors so his way over our heads
there was one textbook a wonderful
beautiful book by a guy named
Leuenberger that was only 100 pages long
which also attempted to unify these two
theories and every page was so dense it
took the three of us three hours to
figure out every page it was an
incredible experience I don't know how
much I learned or retained but I sure
learned a lot of language and
nomenclature and the confidence to learn
about Oh are the economic side of me was
equally exciting the MIT Economics
Department then was considered to be
probably the best along with Harvard and
probably Berkeley and still is one of
the very best if not the best and
especially mathematical I put myself
through the two semester graduate
microeconomics curriculum now economists
in the audience should go whew that's I
mean like that's their weeding out thing
and when I went to college in those days
there were stories about large public
universities where they get up in the
required geography course or something
with
two thousand kids in it and it's reputed
it's probably dis legendary mythology
that the professor would say look to
your left look to your right one of you
will be gone by the end of this semester
well that's what the graduate micro
sequence is like nmit it was a bear but
it allowed me I got through it because I
didn't man i was the only non economics
major which was kind of cool I was an
engineer to they know what to make of me
but hidden matter because you know I
didn't you know who cares if I got a C
or B C is like failing it didn't matter
just so I got through it but allowed me
to take graduate welfare economics from
Paul Salmons now that's a name you know
Samuelson at that time even then was old
no he's he's still a lot of it it's
going to be like a hundred and for my
thesis which I'll come back to you I was
actually really getting deeply in the
welfare economics and I read everything
he had written which and the way he
taught the course was perfect for me
he'd be kidding at this point his career
to become a lousy teacher fact you might
have always been a lousy teacher I don't
know but at this point in his career he
would come in and there would be a
particular topic for the day and he
would just sort of go on about the
people he knew and little anecdotes from
the time he worked on that topic which
was someone at read everything he's ever
written it was phenomenal in the last
ten minutes he'd hand out had written
notes and quickly go over and that was
it this was an amazing experience for me
I realized and really pretty much after
in the fact that this sill engineer
quote-unquote went to Penn to learn how
to build bridges not interested
environment and now I was doing more
operations research in economics really
didn't like engineering and science and
after all what I really liked was
mathematics still do and the ability to
use mathematics get insight into
phenomena but especially into social
issues and you can think about water and
environmental issues as big social
issues I found my calling is too strong
I wound up in the right place let's put
it that way MIT or the scoop at MIT
wanting to put in a practice when
Harvard and conceived of also had taken
on a huge complicated project in
Argentina funded by the United Nations
where they were going to design this is
actually really arrogant but they're
going to use these new fangled water
resource systems techniques to design a
whole river basin development of big
river that when all the way from the
Andes western Atlantic Ocean in the east
totally undeveloped in Argentina and we
were going to find the solutions we
never did predictably they failed
politically which was a great learning
experience but other great experiences
that I've learned from was looking with
my Argentine classmates classmates which
was great fun in every way and also
extending this point about failing in
solution sir the hubris of models now
this was a time when we there really was
a feeling thanks to the US Defense
Department that we could use models to
solve everything business problems
government the problems certainly
military problems which were our was
especially successful where was born and
even natural resource problems like
water resources management and social
problems would come next I learned some
great lessons there about how
that just doesn't work I faculty and
David marks in particular gave me the
extraordinary freedom to do a thesis
like one they had never approved before
in the history of their department I
basically did an extended literature
review of everything written about a sub
sub maybe subfield and mathematical
programming called multi objective
program which became centerpiece of all
of my work from that point on and
eventually a book based on my thesis it
was a great experience along the way
another important person in our lives
and that was our daughter Halle now I
mentioned this nelly because my daughter
has been a source of incredible personal
satisfaction and joy but because she
without knowing it contributed greatly
to my success you know what newborn
babies are like our daughter was born in
my second year graduate school and at
MIT the requirement was that you take
your qualifiers at the end of your
second semester of your of your fourth
semester second semester your second
year and the qualifiers then provided to
afford a take-home exam followed by in
two or three weeks a three-hour oral
exam it's a take-home that this take
home exam literally meant you worked on
this every waking moment you didn't take
time out to eat you ate obviously but
while you're working on the exam you
worked on it every minute you had I had
a newborn babe you know the first night
she ever slept through the night was the
first night in that exam
and of course he slept through the night
every other night after that she still
sleeps through the night David marks my
advisor had studied at Johns Hopkins
that's when he got his PhD so I was in
my last year of graduate work and he
said so Jerry there was a child open at
Johns Hopkins once you apply for ya soon
I applied for it and I interviewed and
got the job and by the way that's how
I've gotten every job since then I'll
tell you about that in a minute it's
extraordinary I didn't go looking just
sort of what's presented to it
unbelievably lucky just one side note
about my negotiating skills so I went to
Baltimore interview and came home in two
days later the chair of the department
called me and I answer the phone and
this is the side of the conversation
bunny ears it was a great negotiator
really rough me a job that much I'll
take
she was furious an idiot you don't
accept a job like that how much did they
offer you thirteen thousand dollars we
felt rich for a month or so maybe more
like an hour so i was at Jass hopkins
from nineteen seventy three to nineteen
ninety two or i spent most of my
academic career and as lucky as I was to
arrive at MIT at that special moment
when they created this new program I was
equally lucky to find myself in a unique
department at Johns Hopkins called doggy
academically that's a word standing for
a department of geography and
environmental engineering it's unique
because who also put together geography
environment earring but they did it was
a result of the sort of burst of
interest on campuses in
multidisciplinary environmental
coursework and programs but unlike most
of them this one survived and still is
thriving today it was largely then
actually exclusively a graduate program
now still largely a graduate program it
was a small faculty of about varied
between 15 and 20 in it for him the
gamut from very traditional engineers to
marxist geographer David Harvey actually
was on campus her last semester I missed
him unfortunate i was out of town when
he was here i would like to see me
brilliant he's a wonderful guy all held
together by this remarkable man named am
Gordon Loman better known as Reds woman
who was phenomenal he was a fiscal
geographer geomorphologist and just was
curious and interested in everything and
somehow made this thing work I was also
incredibly lucky to join Hopkins in this
department two years after another guy
did a guy named Charles Ravel
chuck was just like me in a lot of
respects he was trained as a water
resource systems analyst but it was very
different from me and we were perfect
complements in the following sense we
share the interest in law and resources
and in operations research he had a dish
inul interest in location theory I had
this interest in multijet the
programming we put them together and did
some wonderful things with it chuck was
the image who Chuck by the way died two
years ago he was the image of the
old-time academic that unfortunately
research universities like Johns Hopkins
in carnegie mellon just don't
accommodate anymore by that I mean he
was a dreamer he didn't know from
raising money or getting grants he tried
but he was incredibly terrible at it he
just wasn't good at it but he was always
thinking of problems always I mean full
time I mean I his wife Penny would
surely napkins where he was doodling on
problems he was brilliant and wonderful
I was very good at raising one and
managing students and managing the money
we had we did everything together we
taught together we did all of our
research together all of our projects
were together it was called for ten
years the Chuck and Jerry show which was
terrific we produce just some wonderful
things together many many students there
was time at I'm sort of in our heyday
when we had three major projects and 17
PhD students all going at once it was
really incredible on those students have
gone on to great things that great
universities and the federal government
and elsewhere so that started in 1973
doggy was not actually part of an
engineering school because there wasn't
one your part of the school of arts and
sciences a chance
because Hopkins as did some other elite
research universities in the mid-60s
abolish their engineering school Yale
did that I don't Princeton ever had one
what if they did they would have gotten
rid of theirs too however did they did
this because there was this fashion in
the 60s where engineering got more and
more engineering science like in
ultimately sites and the feeling was why
should we have an engineering school it
just separates our colleagues from
sciences where they belong and Hopkins
got rid of those they realized their
mistake by 1979 when they reestablish
the engineering school it's called the
whiting school and I got a call from the
dean of the new whiting school who asked
me to come and see him and he said Jerry
you may be promoted in the next few
months wink wink I didn't actually know
I was up for promotion to full professor
which was fast Hopkins standards Hopkins
was actually slower than seeing you in
this regard and would you consider being
my assistant dean on a part-time basis
and only for the first time and you'll
see I've had a career of this I believe
in not saying no to your boss so I said
sure Dave they by the way was a
three-time Carnegie Mellon debris
recipient sure Dave I'll be assistant
dean so I became assistant dean and then
I became associate in the next year and
then it became full-time associate dean
and that put me on this administrative
track that got me through to 1986 and
then I got a call like the call I'd
gotten from the DM engineering from the
Provost 1986 saying we're thinking of
creating this new position called vice
provost for research would you do it I
live by my rule of not saying no to my
boss and I said
I'll be vice provost for research the
worst job I ever had but it's a fine job
here at Carnegie Mellon Hopkins is
another story really I could go into
that but I don't want to take up the
time I'm going on too long as it is I
learned a lot of lessons from that
six-year stint as vice promising
research number one is it's really good
not to have a medical school number two
is the way you do budgeting as an
enormous impact on faculty willingness
to collaborate and your ability to do
that and the third thing was about
managing people I never I managed a lot
of PhD students and that's a whole
different thing teach these students are
wonderful students are wonderful people
that work for you sometimes ain't and I
actually had to fire a guy and this is a
very senior guy it was the worst day of
my professional career that's the kind
of thing you have to do i need to
digress for a minute to add to my forest
gump like life so early in my time at
Johns Hopkins so I have to add a little
more context so based on what you heard
about how what I got interested in MIT
and that's what I continue to work on it
happens my interest is was and still is
basically in how the public which say
governments make decisions about major
public investments like water resources
development or environmental protection
how does that happen what are the
methods to support that kind of decision
making the fact is I didn't know a thing
about how the government really our
government really made such decisions
I'd read books about it in papers and
realize that political scientists didn't
have much to say about that either sorry
if I offended anybody
I should say they had a lot to say about
it but I wish they really knew about
what went on and I mentioned would be
interesting to be part of that to learn
and that was that so out of the blue a
few months later I get a call from
Senator morning so after a few hours or
an hour trying to figure out whether
there was a Maryland State Senator one
hand realizing there wasn't and based on
the telephone number this had to be
Senator Pat Moynihan I called back and I
was offered a job how did this happen
well one of my graduate students
finished them and went to work at the
Brookings Institute keep that in mind
now move over downtown to the Capitol
Moynihan is in markup on the clean air
act in a meeting of the Senate
Environment and Public Works Committee
which he was a member and he turns to
his legislative assistant Elliott Abrams
by the way you might know of he went to
jail during the iran-contra affair
that's another issue and he said what
the hell is co2 and Elliott said I don't
know
and you'll pardon me for saying this is
the way morning and talk god damn it
finally for someone who does so the word
went out from the staff and one of the
staff members checker Finn when quite
yet joined morning this is very early in
when hands tenders Senate is the only
like two years two months in his term
was at brookings sorry my horror
syphilis and resources for the future
which is next door to brookies so this
checker Finn from horny ins office said
I'll go next to the door no resources
for the future to try to find an
environmental expert comes across my
former student says I know someone who
would like to work in Washington for you
that's when the call came from that was
an amazing experience so I work from
when a hand in 1977-78 for about 12
months as his legislative system for
energy and environment it was a
phenomenal year for all sorts of reasons
one of us was morning at himself was
quite a character in a brilliant guy but
just seeing the processing part of the
Senate process was terribly exciting and
there were some lessons some important
ones i learned there and this is
something that applies everywhere so as
you might imagine i spent probably the
first two weeks say to myself what are
you doing here Jerry I mean you're just
a middle-class kid from cleveland ohio
and here you are talking app at 18 and
gary hart oh and Ed muskie does the or
environmentalists know how powerful that
name is and you're talking to them like
you know what you're talking about
what are you Jerry Cohen of all the
stunts I like Humphrey Bogart and
Casablanca all the millions of
middle-class kids in America what are
you doing in my bar in my US Senate and
then I realized well someone's got to do
it and you know the wheel stopped up by
name so let's do it and I did and it was
actually learning how to talk to
important people is kind of an acquired
art they're kind of like dogs in the
sense that they will Boye that sound
yeah they sense fear in people like you
can be intimidated and I'll intimidate
you especially senators so you've got it
like know you'd be relaxed calm the way
I am in front of you right now I didn't
spill my water take some getting used to
and then talking to senators is its own
skill because you got to talking short
sentences and not complicate things too
much might enhance favorite I was kind
of though like his house scientists like
his pet monkey away and I would do
tricks so he would if I was on the floor
when he was you know it was a lot
because this is the year that he Carter
National Energy Act one time emotionally
over he was sitting with Metzenbaum
senator Metzenbaum who by the way he
hated and he said motion is it dr. Cohen
you have to visualize someone who can
talk what is ABT u like I was getting it
done exam it's a british thermal unit
equal to thank you dr. Cohen and I walk
away and he was very proud that he
showed off
yeah he had introduced me as having just
been plucked from my physics laboratory
at johns hopkins university tomorrow
hand there was no difference between
physics and engineering or biology if it
wasn't the social sciences you didn't
know so in 1997 sorry 1992 i got a call
out of the blue this time was from Yale
you've been recommended for the deanship
of school for internal studies would you
like to apply I said why not I had done
six years of I sponsor research it
really was an issue what I would do next
that I really want to go back to doggie
which I love to do it was worth looking
at so I went one thing leads to another
they offered me the job and I went there
and that was a great experience Yale as
a phenomenal University one thing I
learned is how different Yale is she
Johns Hopkins how different now I know
Carnegie Mellon is who both of those
that was really a valuable thing one
just little factoid and moved from Yale
so about a week into my job as dean of
forestry normal studies I'm going back
over our finances for the eighth time
and I realize the endowments of the Yale
School of forcing rental studies then
was big enough that I could close the
doors that day never accept another
student or a single research grant and
be able to pay everybody's salary in
perpetuity it's quite a position to be
in but you know we felt poor as Church
mice I don't it was a really this very
strange psychology anyhow that's not
currently melon
not about to close the doors all right
so finally in the ultimate Forrest Gump
event so I'm sitting my office minding
my own business being Dean of forcing
our most studies and I get a call I get
a call from Gary Gary I know because he
is in natural resources at Michigan sort
of a sister school to Yale's 4z school
and good friends with a hind school
professor here who was like co-chairing
the search for the presidency was the
1997 1996 gary said Jerry you want to be
President of Carnegie Mellon I said oh
well they didn't put you want to be a
candidate for president garland I said
no yeah I'm in my fifth year Yale I just
got reappointed to a second five-year
term and things are going great I don't
want to leave he said don't say no call
him and talk to bunny it was small
enough to say that and I'll call you
back tomorrow I said okay so i went home
and we're having a typical dinnertime
conversation how was your day fine and
he knew no oh yeah Gary called and he
want to know what I want to apply to be
president of Carnegie Mellon funny asked
so what'd you say I said no she said
dummy do you want to be a college
president I said yes so something wrong
with Carnegie Mellon no call him back
and tell them we'll be a candidate Gary
call the next thing I said well I guess
I'll be a candidate and amazing i mean
this is this really is the way it
happened yeah so there was a dinner
meeting with a trustee and a faculty
member in Greenwich Connecticut
convenient to me and a meeting and off
campus at the bear guest house because
the only one to try to keep the
candidates secret
and then money and I were invited to
campus for a couple of days and then
chairman the board i'll show you how
naive i am called me up and yale and
said can I fly up to talk to you about
the presidency so we try to figure out
whether that many was an offering a job
or not and it's so stupid why else would
he fly I mean he's so polite he's coming
to tell me well you know decided on
someone else but showing I was no better
I that I had not acquired any better
negotiating skills when he offered me
the job and the money I said that much
yeah well I gotta think about it
incredible things have happened to me in
my career early life one of the most
incredible is that I am the president of
Carnegie Mellon so you know you ask the
question why am I here like in the
Senate case and I still ask myself that
question 10 years later I mean why do I
deserve all people to be president of
this incredible institution and I come
up with the same answer well you got
lucky so stop asking just do it but
there's another question in this case
which is why am I still here not in the
sense of why why why wouldn't I go
elsewhere I mean why would you want me
still to be here that's doesn't quite
summer I you I figured that I would last
ten years if I could and then I got
offered a third five-year term which as
you know I accepted so the question
really is why do I seem to fit into the
presidency at Carnegie Mellon that's the
question I'm asking myself and the best
I've been able to come up with as an
answer is that the interdisciplinary
thing I mean that's my whole career has
been about that that's in my blood in
the same way it's in carnegie mellon's
DNA
the Carnegie Mellon interest in
practical solutions and I can be
theoretical but everything I've done has
been most started with engineering a
problem this is going a bit too far but
I would guess I would venture to say the
way Carnegie Mellon's develops sort of
organically one way to put this as
Carnegie Mellon's life plan is not so
different from mine which is to say
there isn't a plan that didn't sound
quite right either we had a plan we have
a strategic plan what our plan really is
is to identify areas where interested in
priorities that were you want to pursue
and when opportunities arise we jump in
when the phone rings are ready to say
yes and finally I guess one part of this
is why it did I stay here if there were
opportunities to go elsewhere and there
it's easy Carnegie Mellon is University
incredibly easy to admire and it's a
privilege to be part of people have had
everything to do with my success bunny
who saved my academic career or not my
life and we not got gotten married who
knows if I'm be in jail still
arai sondhi for introducing me to
environmental engineering and give me
the opportunity to work in it s he is
research assistants David marks for
lemme part be part of a great adventure
in terms of shaping a new field in
chakra vel who is just the best
colleague anybody could have so with
that I don't mean embarrass you but
money when you come up here please
please
if I would have known you were going to
ask me to come up here I'm gonna dress
nicer that's it I think she she did not
teach me how to dress to say otherwise
we to embarrass her in that so this
whole lecture series about journeys and
Buddy not only kept me on some kind of
path but it absolutely has been my
partner throughout this journey I want
to thank you thank you thank you
so Cathy and Derek told me I could
invite questions I went longer than they
wanted me to but I'm the president so I
get there snow up there as long as I one
or you can leave I was just wondering if
you think maybe the reason that you fit
so well with private rooms because
you're such a such a bird
you know I sign everybody's check-in
affectionate way well how does one
answer that question gee I never thought
of myself as a nerd I've never been
called a nerd but if that's what it
takes I can be a nerd no I think just to
pick up on other theme we have
incredible diversity of people at this
university and by that I mean not only
racially geographically but also in
terms of interests and in personalities
and we got nerves we got nerds in every
field that we do things it so we got
arts nerds as well as engineering herbs
but we got people who are nerds either
and I rather like that we make room for
all of them and I think everybody
benefits from it you gave me something
to think about them see my nerd
Walter wavin we got to get you in like
sorry oh I blew my cover my saying i
love mathematics I like it our nerds are
the best sorry Kathy I got to run all
the way back to fro yeah what'd she do
here person and fret on the back pork in
your piano you were in a band great
question so you know i was very tempted
if head i had time i might have put
together like pictures to support all
this sin but then I realized who would
wanted to see pictures of meat however
there's one exception and that's our
band photo it's very cool just to prove
i'm not a nerd it's true at johns
hopkins i was part of a band called the
new Krusty nostrils
now for those that there should be
enough people close enough here to
remember this and then explain it to
other people there was a group in the
50s and 60s called a new Christy
Minstrels they were the height of white
bread America pablum vanilla just the
kind of thing the 60s were all against
and and so new Christy new Krusty
nostrils was enough take off on new
Christy Minstrels we we I was the
drummer and the all the other players
for my graduate students and then we
were fronted by a girl's singing group
they call themselves a girl singing
group called the nacelles so is the
formal name was the new Krusty nostrils
featuring the fabulous and exotic nasals
and any particular gig is buried from
three to nine days else and they love
dressing up it was great we were pretty
bad but there were we had two phenomenal
musicians the lead guitarist the basis
the trauma really was bad but they
carried me and one really good singer
and that's all you need the other secret
was if things aren't going well turn it
up if they're still not going well play
fast and the foolproof one was wait to
the crowd had more drinks and then the
films were actually it was great for
about three years we were the hottest
band around and we even got a gig in
downtown Baltimore in the air harbor
area and
we all thought we had died and gone to
heaven we you did a Friday Saturday
night thing at the oh sorry the band was
going to break up after this because the
bassist in the lead singer were going to
France and they finish their PhDs that
was the one flaw in our plan and I let
them finish and so we do fine Saturday
night Saturday nights over the owner
comes up to us and says we broke records
will you be my house man and we said we
can't were breaking up and he said with
in all seriousness why is it always the
great bands that break up
and that's how we reacted we fell down
laughing it was really a phenomenal for
years you didn't ask they can see it
touch this warm spot here we played
everything from Elvis Presley Elvis
Costello and everything in between a lot
of b-52s a lot of Ramon's they like the
Ramones a lot of tunes on would never
admit that we played it was we were
great thanks for asking I think by the
way that's the only thing that wikipedia
says about me right Wikipedia is all up
to you come on get online how about that
nerd President Fred listen I predicting
shoot for example she drops when you're
25 I haven't got the things I was 25 now
you said that kind of God your GPA but
could you try to
not change and you got me so that is so
much nicer thank you for a sec Fred out
it has to point out Fred got married
that so long ago and his wife is sitting
next to him so I'll be very careful
about what I say or in my case you had
particularly big impact because I was so
immature and bunny was mature enough for
both of us recently yeah I was 19 when I
got married and with the mind of a
nine-year-old well maybe 12 and so I you
know Fred I think more than anything it
was so she was she quit school after her
sophomore year to put me through school
and then graduate school and it was only
after our daughter was born and was in
grade school that she went back to
finish her bachelor's degree and then go
in law school which is a remarkable she
I could have never done them so knowing
that she'd quit school and she was
working full time it was a little hard
for me to behave the way I had been
behaving before I got married and I
won't elaborate on how I was made in
before we got married so it was a sense
of obligation to her and the sacrifice
she was made and then eventually about
five years ago I finally matured to the
point of being more or less self
sufficient
I'm not self-sufficient give me five
more years that's why I got reappointed
the board wants to see if I can make it
to self-sufficiency before do you have
any favorite ambitious for yourself with
school thank you well yes for the school
absolutely you know that's one cannot be
a carnegie mellon without embracing the
tendency to aspire to be always better
and that bigger impact that's the way
Carnegie Mellon has always been and
that's the way it is now so I'm what
very much to have more for hurting them
more in a sense of better funding more
notoriety for the great things that we
do and even bigger reputation than the
one we have as we deserve all those
things but I'm not out to make it bigger
although I have to amend that I guess we
have become global heavily and it's a
little hard to be intimate with campus
half a world away and that we surely are
pursuing but we're not our ambitions are
not to get much better than we are one
thing I said that when I became
president that you'll be able to sit
there's one thing you'll be able to say
for sure when I retired that cohen did
not start a medical school a law school
or a major sports program so in that
sense I don't aspire to those things but
absolutely we always want to get better
here and I want that for very mellow to
you
being on campus here and experienced
students at the culture in different
colleges on campus I is a core turning
even a student which is very common is
that same in common even globally we put
a nigga valid student at our canvas be
very identical to a student here so that
is the central question and challenge
for us as we become global absolutely
the center was there are related
questions which flow from that but
that's where it starts those who have
gone to the cutter campus recently will
come back and say I knew it was a
Carnegie Mellon facility not just
because of the posters that say Cardinal
that it's different from Cornell's in
Texas A&M Georgetown's and it is
reflective of the Carnegie Mellon
culture but I'm not kidding myself it
can't be the same as Carnegie Mellon
Pittsburgh just as Carnegie Mellon
Adelaide can't be the same as Cardinal
in Pittsburgh so the issue we have to
figure out is what does Carnegie Mellon
X mean where x equals something other
than Pittsburgh and are we satisfied
that we are retaining the essence of
what Carnegie Mellon is in these remote
campuses that's the big challenge I
think it's doable I think it's happening
but I'm not saying one in any event your
hardest constant vigilance thank you
very very much for coming to this
lecture which was special to me thank
you very much
you